when I look up at the night sky from
Cambridge I can only see a few dozen
stars from the dark mountaintops where I
use telescopes I can see thousands yet
even this is a small fraction of all
that's out there our Milky Way galaxy
contains hundreds of billions of stars
and 70% of all of these stars are a type
of star we call red dwarfs but even from
those dark mountaintops you won't see a
single red dwarf even the closest and
brightest it's too faint to be seen
without the aid of a telescope after
five years of researching and learning
and teaching about the stars in our
galaxy I sometimes imagine that I can
see some of our galaxy's small red stars
what excites me the most about these
stars are the planets we are finding
around them we are on a quest to find a
planet like Earth a planet similar in
size and with the right temperature for
liquid water a planet with the potential
for life as we know it but finding a
planet like Earth is difficult and
learning about what it's made of or
what's in its atmosphere is even harder
with the methods we use to make these
measurements it is easier to find in to
study planets around smaller stars and
the smallest stars in the universe are
red dwarfs these stars are about quarter
the size of the Sun but hundreds of
times fainter instead of emitting most
of their light at optical colors like
the Sun they emit most of their light in
the infrared where our detector
technology has not been as advanced
moreover our theoretical models don't
yet explain their fundamental stellar
properties such as size age or spend as
a result these are one of the least well
studied type of star and we don't yet
have a good understanding of the physics
I'm intrigued by the mysteries these
doors hold but these uncertainties pose
a fundamental problem for learning about
the planets around them the reason is
that we measure the properties of the
planet only relative to the properties
of the star so if for example we have
any uncertainties about the Stars size
or similarly uncertain about the planets
size without knowledge of the basic
physical properties of red dwarf stars
how can we hope to understand the
planets that orbit them it's to address
this issue that I turned my attention to
this type of star due to the
uncertainties in our theoretical models
I take an observational approach to
studying these stars
I used Harvard's Magellan telescope in
Chile and NASA's infrared telescope
facility in Hawaii employing a technique
called spectroscopy for each star the
final result is a spectrum like this one
which shows the brightness of the star
at different colors or wavelengths of
light
I measured spectra for 600 of the most
nearby red dwarf stars obtaining
thousands of individual observations
each of these spectra contains clues to
the Stars properties atoms and molecules
within the stars absorb light at
specific colors creating distinct
spectral signatures in this red door
spectrum the deep troughs are due to
absorption by atoms of aluminum and
magnesium I measure the depths of these
dips because the strength of these
features depend on the Stars properties
I looked for patterns in the spectra
correlating the depths of features like
these against different stellar
properties after carefully considering
the many possibilities I found new
relationships between the depths of
specific features and the star's
temperatures diameters and chemical
compositions I calibrated these
relationships using a small sample of
stars whose properties we can directly
and then I took my calibrations and
applied them to the stars that I had
surveyed even though these are some of
the most nearby stars to us for many of
them it was the first time we learned
about their properties with accuracy
I also took my calibrations and applied
them to stars already known to have
planets around them
one example is kepler 372 a red dwarf
star with three planets using my
technique I showed that the star is
actually 15% bigger than we had
previously thought and because we
measure the properties of the planets
only relative to the properties of the
star this means that the planets are 15%
bigger to this change in size can be the
difference between a rocky earth-like
planet and one was significantly more
gas like Uranus or Neptune we lived in
an era where it is possible to point to
a star at night and say this star has a
planet around it but it is around the
red dwarf stars that can't be seen that
we have the best prospects for finding
and studying habitable rocky worlds it's
the planets orbiting these stars whose
atmospheres we will be able to study
with the next generation of telescopes
and on which we will first have the
capability of finding signs of life by
learning more about our red dwarf
neighbors I hope to accelerate us
towards a future where we can ask and
answer new scientific questions about
the earth-like planets that orbit other
stars thank you